- Good morning Believe Nation,
my name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe and I
believe that entrepreneurs will
solve all of the world's major problems.
So to help on your journey,
today's message is shine.
Over to you Tupac Shakur.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- I can't explain why ...
I shine and no one else shines.
I think everybody shines,
in different things, and a
lot of things I can't do.
I can't play basketball like every other
black person in America,
but I can act.
I know how to go to
that true spot in myself
'cuz I'm there every day.
I can be me. I can be whoever,
because I'm true to me.
I can go to neutral easily.
A lot of people, black,
white, Mexican, young or old,
fat or skinny, have a problem
being true to they self.
They have a problem looking in the mirror
and looking directly into their own souls.
The reason I sell six million records,
the reason I can go to jail
and come out without a scratch,
the reason I can walk around,
the reason I am who I am today
is because I can look
directly into my face
and find my soul, it's there.
It's not sold. I didn't sell
it, it's there within me.
I still feel it. My heart is
still connected to my body.
So I could, any character I'm a bring
that intensity, that truth
and that honestly to it
because I have to repay for that blessing,
from black Jesus, from God.
I have to pay for that, by shining.
If he gives you the
voltage, and you waste it,
that's the curse. He gave
me the voltage, I'm a shine.
It's not mines, its from God. It's God.
Not that its so special
that no body got it, but
all of our gifts and blessings and,
and our strengths and our
weaknesses come from God,
come from black Jesus, or whoever,
comes from within you. You know I mean?
So, it's not really
tricky, everybody can do it
if they can just go to that spot.
I guess all the things that
happened to me in my life
allow me to go there easily.
- I believe that everybody
has genius-level talent
at something.
Everybody, has genius-level
talent at something.
People just don't know what it is.
People just coast.
They sit on their talent, or
they never even discover it.
I can say that Michael Jordan
is not the greatest basketball
player of all time, that the
greatest basketball player of
all time is the manager at Starbucks,
because he didn't chase
his basketball dreams.
Or because he never even
picked up a basketball.
Right? And so how many people
sit on their ambitions,
sit on their dreams, sit on their desires,
and don't actually take the action?
You could have been Michael
Jordan in what you did,
but instead you're doing
this thing you're doing.
That's most people.
They wake up and they drive
to go work for somebody they
don't like, in a job that
doesn't maximize their talents.
They work with people who,
you know, don't respect them
as much as they should, and
they do that every single day
for the rest of their lives.
That's what most people
wake up to do, and that's really sad.
But it's no body else's
fault, besides your own.
I believe it's your responsibility
to go and find the thing
that you have genius-level talent at,
that you can shine with.
And some of you know it.
Some of you know, like I can
be the best in the world,
or among the best in the world at this.
You know it.
But you're just not taking
enough action on it.
You're not committing
enough to it, you're not
practicing hard enough to
get to where you want to go.
Michael Jordan had
talent, but he practiced.
He worked harder than anybody
on the Bulls, as well.
You got to own your craft,
and practice and work it
every single day.
So some of you know what
you could have the potential
to be great at, but you're
not putting in the work
to get there. You're coasting.
You've reached a certain
level, you're coasting 'cuz
its easy for you to do that
level, you don't have to
put a lot of practice
and preparation into it.
You know, you have other
responsibilities and so you're
kind of coasting on this one
thing that you're talented at.
Some of you don't even know it.
Some of you have no idea
what you're talented at.
You have no idea what your genius-level,
Michael Jordan level, at.
And so that's you that
you need to explore.
Like that manager at Starbucks,
if he never picked up
a basketball, he would never know
he would be better than Michael Jordan.
So you have to explore.
You have to say yes.
You have to try things.
If you have no idea what your
passion or your purpose is,
then say yes to almost anything.
You know as long as its
legal, as long as it
doesn't cause bodily harm.
There's a few criteria,
but in general say yes to everything,
and its something I
still try to adopt today.
I say yes to new experiences.
Say yes to trying out new things.
Say yes to going to new countries.
Say yes to try new food.
Say yes to going to new events.
Say yes, until you know.
You know, you say yes to
trying that piece of sushi
and you figure out I like sushi.
Great we don't have to do that again.
That's the definition of insanity, right?
Its going back and doing the
same thing over and over again
and expecting a different result.
If you've tested it and then you know,
well I don't like rock
climbing. I don't like the thing
in my crotch. I don't
like heights. I tried it.
I said yes, I tried it
... I didn't like it.
Great, I don't have to go do it again.
But if you don't know what
it is that you love to do,
then you have to try. You say
yes, you say yes, you say yes,
until you find the thing that
makes you come alive that you
want to do over and over and
over and over and over again,
until you shine.
You have Michael Jordan
level talent in something,
and it desperately wants you to find it
and act on it, to make a positive impact,
not just for yourself, but your community,
the people around you, your family,
and the world.
So the question of the day today
is, I'm curious, two parts.
One, do you know,
what you have Michael
Jordan level talent at?
And two, if you do, what is it?
Both yes or no question and the answer,
leave in the comments below.
I'm real excited to find out.
I also want to give a
quick shout-out to Mzi Tom.
Thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book Your One Word. I
really appreciate the support
and I hope you enjoyed the read.
So thank you guys so much for watching,
I believe in you. I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word
is, much love and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for
another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
(typewriter clicking)
- You know my mother used to tell me,
"Todd, you can do anything
you put your mind to."
And my grandmother used to tell me,
"If a task is once begun,
never leave it til its done.
"Be the labor great or small,
do it well or not at all."
And I kind of grew up with
that mantra, you know?
- I grew up believing that
you could do anything you
put your mind to, you know?
And I don't ...
No matter what, you know,
I am extremely determined.
- Like I'm like, abnormally--
- Its like that need to
succeed, never goes away, right?
- It's not only, it's
not just a general like--
succeed--
- [TT] It's that fire.
- for the success, for
the sake of succeeding,
its a desire to create.
- [TT] Yeah.
- You know I'm saying?
To use the Godly power and
talent that was instilled in me
to the best of my ability,
to maximize my potential.
Because if I'm not here
to maximize my potential,
then what am I on earth for?
- Well my message to the
youth pretty much man,
is just to follow your
dreams, you know what I mean?
I think a lot of people get
caught up and get sidetracked
by what's happening around
them, and what's cool.
People always ignore they
gift, no realizing that gift
is what's going to take
you out of your poverty,
take you out of your situation.
That gift is the ultimate
element that God provided for you
to get you out of any situation,
or to take you to what
destined for you. You, know,
some people are just great at
certain things, but
because music, or modeling,
or film is cool, they
alienate what their gifts are
just to be a part of something
that is pursued to be,
or persuaded to be cool.
So I always felt like, you know, my method
and message always has been,
to just follow the gift that you have,
put a lot of emphasize in it.
Concentrate on what you
feel that you're great in,
because what you're great in,
is always going to be what pulls you out
of the worst situations
that you could ever imagine,
and put you in a better
situation, like being in debt.
When you fully accept that
you are here to be great,
when you fully accept that
you are here to be happy,
you're here to receive,
when you fully accept that you can have
the peace and the serenity,
and the joy and the wisdom,
and the purpose and the intention
that you intend to bring to the world,
and that it is all available to you.
That's is when life gets very groovy.
And so my hope and my intention for today,
is to wake you up to that
presence and more importantly,
give you a really great New
York City kick in the ass that
says not only I'm awake to it,
not only do I believe in it,
but I am committed to it.
I am unapologetic about
my capacity to be great.
my capacity to heal.
I am unapologetic about my capacity to see
beyond my physical sight.
I am unapologetic about my capacity to
shine as bright as I can shine,
because I trust and I know
that when I shine bright,
I give others permission to do the same
and in my glow they wake up too,
and that
is why we're here.